so
somebody had tweeted out something which
was like hey if you needed a side hustle
that was going to generate like 3k to 5k
a month
um
and you could only kind of work like you
know let's say like
you know a couple hours and during the
week and and you know half a day on the
weekends or something like that what
would you do to do that if you didn't
know how to code
[Music]
are we
good i'm a whole different guy sampar
i'm
you're looking at a man
four days in
to clean eating
and guess what
now i'm on time
guess what now my kids love me
guess what
the stocks went up today for the first
time in like five months so a lot of
things are going well here
what are you eating
i'm just
like i don't know if this is healthy or
not but i'm very heavy meat and protein
right now and just like nothing bad and
not eating late not not doing bad stuff
dude listen to this thing that i'm doing
it's called um
my body tutor have you heard of it
i have heard of this is it like a text
messaging thing somebody like
it's way more primitive than that so
basically i pay them either six or seven
hundred dollars a month i don't remember
if it's 5.99 or 6.99 and this woman
named heather she's like my coach she
just calls me every single morning and i
have to tell her what i ate what i'm
gonna eat today
and then she tell and i
write down on my fitness pal what i've
eaten the day before and she'll say
yesterday was bad or good here's why
tell me what you're gonna eat today
that's all it is it's a five minute
phone call and it's
it's amazing
it's it's it's you should try this it's
actually i should try this
the fact that i don't want to try this
tells me that i absolutely should try
this so i think i might i think i might
do it because
uh
yeah i don't know it's
i've i'm uh i'll i'll tell you what i'll
tell you what's i'll tell you what's
embarrassing what's embarrassing was
that a day and a half into just eating
clean is just not
not like you know oh my daughter's
leftover macaroni and cheese all right
let me just eat these three spoons
before i put it in the sink or like oh
there's a free cookie here at this thing
let me just grab that
um a day and a half in i felt a
difference which tells me
how
poorly i had been eating if i could feel
a difference just from a day and a half
of of eating perfectly right uh what do
you eat normally that's bad like are you
talking about like process just clean
meat just like no sugar not processed no
sugar not processed um
not like late night snacking or whatever
like just cutting it off at a certain
time
um
and then not like okay you know
i've been like you know what what will
happen to me sometimes is i'll be like
oh i'm working i got calls i got the pod
i got all this stuff going on i'm
excited i look up it's 2 p.m i haven't
eaten anything and i'm like all right
the next edible item in sight is just
getting like devoured right it's like a
stress at that point yeah it's getting
caught
oh you thought this party size of
doritos was for a party no it's getting
got right now and so
so
you ever heard of uh you ever heard of
someone doing a line of oreos it's when
you
when you get the oreo tray and it's got
like three columns and you do a whole
line you just take a whole column out in
one sitting that's something that would
happen before uh you know just on an
inconsistent basis
i like to do oreo cereal you just get a
gallon of milk and a sleeve of oreos and
just
just go to town
so i'm going with you man i like all
that stuff too but you just can't do it
yeah i can't do it um all right so we
got a bunch of stuff let's do uh let's
do some of these topics i don't know
where you want to start oh actually i
just see my topics i don't see yours do
you have any
i had a few we went through a lot of
them the other day but well well one
thing that is quick the classic we went
through a lot of them the other day the
classic
no i'm usually really prepared but did
you see that oh conan o'brien's thing
got acquired team coco
yeah you texted this so what is it so he
has a podcast network or is just his one
podcast it's a podcast network but i
think he's the heavy hitter and
it's a 160 million or something you said
right like a pretty 150 to 200 i forget
the number but they have 16 million
downloads a month
we have two mfm sizes
[Laughter]
we have two or three million a month
so what does that put us worth and ours
is a business like it's the people
listening you guys are richer than like
conan o'brien's audience yeah and we're
way better looking and way more funny so
you know if you just take his multiple
and you say all right divide by eight we
don't do public math so that's
unfortunately just the problem we're not
gonna know how much worth because we go
into public math and moving on to the
next topic i think that's 20 million
dollars
who bought it by the way serious
serious body okay so he's gonna like go
exclusively to them
yeah but honestly
i'm gonna call our shot a little bit i
don't think that it's going to be that
crazy that in a year or two we get paid
like 10 or 20 million a year to license
out to spotify or something like that
i would enjoy that
that sounds a little crazy 10 or 20
million i think sounds a little crazy
but then again like
it sounded crazy that you know like um
for example the ringer when they got
bought by
um by spotify so they were a sports
network of podcasts led by bill simmons
so bill simmons was sort of like the
conan o'brien of that network and they
got bought i think for 200 million
and
and what's crazy is it's not even
exclusive to spotify
which is just like wild to me that
that's how favorable these deals are in
the same way that joe rogan when he got
paid by spotify
he had to take it off of youtube but
uh he's still on the he's still on apple
podcast which is pretty crazy so
when the ringer sold to spotify 200
million i think they were doing about 15
million in revenue when they got bought
for 200. crazy that is absolutely crazy
and was it only one podcast or no they
actually
it was like yeah 12 maybe or something
like that but they've got a few winners
it's like three winners and then like
it's like one big winner two small
winners and a bunch of like long tail
stuff that that kind of doesn't matter
um in terms of of like how how big it is
but also i think for them the other
thing is they won't it's not like they
were bought for a revenue multiple it's
not like spotify was like you know what
we're gonna buy this revenue multiple
because you know that's going to get
priced at a favorable rate in the market
here it was just like
we need to strategically move into
podcasting okay
go get rogan go get the ringer go get
the one that i got bought that's like a
bar rally is that startup one gimlet so
they bought kimlit also for a lot of
money they bought anchor that podcasting
tool that sucked um like not sucked the
tool was cool but nobody was using it uh
they bought that thing for like 150
million which is crazy to me and uh so
they did they splurged and i think you
know that splurge that splurge window is
now closed
well listen if you're a listener and if
you work at sirius or spotify or
something like this and you want to
throw we are motivated by money
yeah
do things because people pay me money so
we can have that conversation
i enjoy commas with many zeros around
them
so anyway if you're listening and you
want to make an introduction or you want
to help us get paid
can we talk about this um okay so i have
a few ideas so i have a couple things i
want to talk about later i want to talk
to you about
this new version of plastic surgery that
i think is interesting
i want to talk to you about a virtual
reality project i saw that was actually
doing some pretty significant revenue
i want to talk to you about um
this like bionic reading thing so i have
a few things i want to talk about but
first
can we talk about this meme the drinking
a cola meme
yeah
so sam texts me while we're on vacation
and uh i was like dude this is perfect
for the pod because you saw a tweet from
moyes who came on the podcast the same
day or the next day or something like
that
and moy said something like i don't know
can you pull it up what the exact
phrasing is but he he was just tweeting
about some business thing he's like oh
yeah i was drinking a cola with the
founders of this blah blah app
and
and then he said some business thing and
sam rightfully pointed out how hilarious
that intro is of like
i was enjoying a cola with my friends
and then we just
decided to start talking about you know
cash flow
i met with the triple whale founders
yesterday for a cola they were exhausted
from a day of traveling but we all we
all left with so much energy genghis
khan conquered 30 of the world during
his reign we want to do the same except
the world is now the digital marketing
share
but the intro was i met with these
founders yesterday
that tweet is hilarious on multiple
levels first of all the
metaphor is founders for cola
hilarious who drinks cola i don't know
who says
first of all that's like who smokes and
drinks soda still i don't know second
who calls it cola third why is that
relevant for the tweet it's
funny
yeah we have to do a series of tweets
where it's like we talk about something
profound but the intro is like uh you
know so i was getting some caramels with
a friend or uh
yeah so
like it just got to be like the most
random stuff
snapping off a beef jerky with my buddy
timmy and he told me about how
self-storage market is really going
under right now it's like yeah
who says a
[Laughter]
cola do you think that's what he meant
as a cult like you sat down for like
pepsi
like
it's like you know
at a board meeting today we poured out
of peppermint schnapps and decided
if we ever do an event or a conference
it's like that's the passcode like how
do we know you're real and you're a real
listener you're real loyal it's like you
need to be able to come up and be like
and tell us a story
tell us a story that starts with like
you know you know so i was eating a
dunkaroo and
you know
just had a question
or we gotta like do the most extreme
thing ever where it's like so i was uh
doing this thing where you suck on a
piece of candy and then spit it in your
friend's mouth because it changed the
taste anyway we were talking about
that's not important but we were talking
about the economic
oh it's so good it's so good
that's my new [__] you know my last [__]
was i have moved straight to the end
because of elon and
i haven't moved straight to the end
that's done and my new [__] is
yeah
my buddy we're doing the spaghetti thing
where we each take one end of the noodle
and suck on it but when we got close to
the middle we realized the problem with
coven
[Music]
and then we started talking about the
recession
that's pretty good drinking a cola
wait really quick do you think that he
was trying to be funny
no that's the best part i think he was
just saying like
i think he was just saying what happened
and that in his mind is what happened
even the second part of the tweet alone
right take the cola part out just being
like i met with the vendors of triple
whale and
you know genghis khan
if you bring genghis khan into whatever
sentence you're saying
you you are dramatically overestimating
whatever you're doing in life
it's like the same way where if anyone's
like yeah um
you know the way that tesla came out
with the roadster first so we're also
doing like a high end of digital
marketing attribution before we go low
end it's like no you're equivalent
you're making yourself equivalent to
tesla and like that's anytime you're
like genghis khan conquered 30 of the
earth whatever the next sentence is
better be [__] lit and instead his
was like we're doing the same for
digital marketing and so that also was
like you know just hilarious to me
is cola
uh
is moi was boys born in america yeah
he's he's born no they were i think they
were born in pakistan and then they
moved when they were like seven or five
or something is that like a pakistani
thing where they call like soda cola
i don't know maybe because actually i
have a cousin who came over from india
but like when he was like 20 and he
would always be like hey can i have a
coca-cola light
what
would you just say and he would like
he would always say the full name of
things and it was like okay yeah like oh
is this covered by nationwide insurance
again it is
funny you ask
[Laughter]
this is awesome we could go on this
forever
yeah
it's too much for me all right so i want
to talk about a couple ideas did you see
this thing about
i have this link in here you can see
it's this the surgery that guys are
getting
that
costs 75 000 but it'll make you three
inches taller do you see this thing
they break your face
that's a great thing to text to like
your friend who like is a little short
you're like hey heard the news good news
congrats
i heard about the break the scientific
breakthrough oh what happened you got a
vaccine no
they break your femur and they'll put a
rod in and it'll make you three to five
inches taller and this thing is like
apparently just popping off
and i've just been looking at this like
it's like what are the big problems that
nobody wants to admit to but are real
i just think that that's an interesting
prompt for business ideas so it's like
our buddy craig clemons does this where
like one of his products is like
one of his best-selling products right
like he's got these d2c companies that
do like i don't know over 100 million a
year in sales uh as part of his like
bootstrap thing
and um
i think one of their products was like
some toenail fungus remover
and it's like just like the unsexiest
thing but it's like common and it's
actually something something that people
really want to get rid of right um or
they're something that people really
want to change
and i think height is another one i've
seen this now in two places so first i
saw this surgery thing and i was like oh
that's funny like the article was
written almost like
can you believe this crazy thing people
are doing and in my mind i was like yeah
i can totally believe that i think being
just
[__] awesome yeah exactly like if
you're gonna be your best friend
or like a fake ass like yeah this is
this is i'm on board exactly and i was
like you know being taller is like you
know just awesome like if you gave me
three inches i'd be very happy i'd earn
more money and i'd be more liked like
that's just a thing like ben how tall
are you like six four right
yeah yes correct
you already know you already know the
advantage you're you're so privileged
dude you shouldn't even talk to the
podcast you're so privileged
you're speaking from tall privilege
right now check your privilege yeah you
need to check your tall privilege at the
door right now i had a
girlfriend one time
not like a girlfriend but like a
girl i was familiar with
who said uh who told me i can't tell if
i think you're actually handsome or if
you're just tall yeah by the way sam did
you in your course there's a review from
me saying like sam's copyrighted course
it works i i got three extra inches in
two weeks or something like that
and uh did you write that because people
keep coming to me to be like that's so
funny
yeah they're like dude that's so funny
and either blacked out or someone is
just impersonating me because i don't
remember writing that but it's hilarious
basically if you go to try copy that dot
com and you scroll all the way down like
on the sales page you'll see like a and
it says sean perry
and then where the review is loved it so
much it gave me three extra inches
totally five out of five stars
i thought you did that which was funny
but the fact that someone else did it
and wrote your your name funnier funnier
dude i knew a guy yeah so this is an
interesting question we i know a guy
named nat
and he's got an app
uh it's called like
i forget what exactly what it's called
but it helps you with a kegel do you
know what a kegel is
i don't i think
i i think a kegel is the exercise that
you do or is it the muscle that needs to
be
stronger it's the exercise it's sick
it's the exercise that you have to do
that keeps you from pre-jacking early i
guess that's an oxymoron
i like how you just shortened it you're
like if i just say half the word it's
half as bad um the other thing i think i
think women do it which is like supposed
to be just like good for you in general
but also
for women it kind of tightens it helps
them feel helps helps sex feel better
for them i think it's the idea um well
this guy and he created an app for men
to keep you from just jacking early and
i think he kills it
i guess let me guess it's doing pretty
well
yeah it's doing good and so that's like
another one i don't know if that's that
big of a market but what else is there i
think it is a huge market i mean look at
what row and hymns did right so they
took erectile dysfunction and they
wrapped a brand that you won't feel
embarrassed you're you know
like associated with around it right
like the value of hymns is is partially
the telemedicine piece which is like you
don't have to go to a doctor and talk to
somebody face to face about this
so it's like reduces shame on one end
and on the other end it reduces shame
the other way which is you get the
package uh there's no label on it it's
like completely discreet and secondly
like they made their brand cooler
so that
you don't feel like a schmuck for you
you don't feel like something's wrong
with you or you're broken in some way
for using them right like that's like
the value of their brand and that's why
they built literally a billion dollar
brand doing that
yeah here's another one
have you ever
like cheese grated your foot to get the
callus off
you don't kind of like
that's
the most country thing you've ever said
no i have never done that like you know
like with parm have you read like oh i
know what you're talking about like
i've seen i've seen a girl doing this on
this like there's like a like the
equivalent of like a sweet potato peeler
or whatever and they just like use that
on their like to get their callus off
their foot
yeah so i just sent it to you
in the uh chat box
it's uh it's basically
i bought one the other day because i had
just like calluses on my foot and it's
basically just a cheese grater like a
like for
parmesan they just call it a foot uh
colossal footrest
a foot files what they call it
it's got almost a hundred thousand
reviews oh my god this thing is 82 000
reviews on amazon
it's just like one reader that they just
have you ever seen a product with more
reviews than that like
has an instapod or whatever has that
many reviews
is that crazy it's a ten dollar
like made in china cheese grater that
they just call a foot file
that is insane uh that probably cost
them 50 cents right
no more than that but like yeah it's
still profitable that's crazy because
they're just gonna get so many searches
right like for something like this
um the other one that's like the height
one that i saw so somebody's doing this
on tick tock and the ad is brilliant so
they're selling a shoe like a men's
platform shoe so it's an insert into a
normal shoe
that's kind of like a heel but instead
of the heel being on the outside of the
shoe it's on the inside
so your foot just like your heel gets
elevated from the inside like a doctor
shoals but like gives you two and a half
inches in inside of a shape better than
surgery just do that way better right
and so
how do they sell this
how do they sell this the tick tock ad
is it looks like um so it's you know
this like i don't know if you've heard
this thing in common like a man on the
street interview where it's basically
like if you ever watch those late night
shows they'll go to like time square
they'll be like uh you know do you
support you know whatever this thing and
then people don't even know what it is
they say stupid stuff but it's basically
like dude walking around with a
microphone out about like times square
outside of a nightclub or like at a bar
and they just like ask questions
and so the ad is a tick tock is on tick
tock and what the guy's doing is or the
girl is um oh no the guy's interviewing
girls
he's like
all right be honest this size matter
when it comes to height for guys right
or like something like that they like
immediately get you of like okay first
this doesn't look like an ad
secondly you kind of want to know what
the girl says
exactly because it's preying on an
insecurity and so then and it just
quickly cuts between the girls and
they'll be like and it ranges from a
girl being like uh like no
okay yeah and then like it's just kind
of like her admitting it and then it's
like the next one is like two girls
they'll be like hell yeah she won't even
date a guy if he's not six five and
she's like no no he's like no tell the
truth it's true
and like and it's kind of like preying
on the guys in security like oh man
girls really care about this they won't
admit it but they but if you get them to
be honest they really do care that that
extra hate matters they'll be like
what's the perfect height for a guy and
then they'll be like um
six one in fact you know the average guy
is my five nine and they're like yeah
and then they're just laughing right and
it's like four of those cuts of like
that interview and then it's like um and
then and then they do an even better
version of it they're like
i've seen one i think that's like the
guy's wearing it and they're like did
you know that he's wearing this thing
right now and they're like no i had no
idea and it's basically like people
can't tell that you're wearing these
things and so they're addressing the
objections that somebody would have so
first they create the demand which is
that like girls will find you more
attractive if you're if you're taller
then they address the objections which
is you don't look goofy for wearing
stilts and like and said they're like oh
i have no idea no you can't tell oh my
god that's awesome like that's so clever
and so they're like and they super cut
that together and i saw that i was like
man this is a really
effective like marketing campaign and
it's also an interesting product
category that i wouldn't have rather
otherwise really thought about
that's actually interesting yeah this is
pretty cool and every that is a good one
that people are embarrassed about they
need to do an ad about how like everyone
who says they're 511 is really just five
nine because no one's actually 511. like
you just yeah if you did a man on the
street you're like how tall are you
they're like yeah five five eleven i'm
six i'm six and they're like okay cool
we have a thing right here just stand up
and they're like five ten six even
though it's five eleven
are you six foot
yeah
that's true
i've never met a six-footer in your life
it's like a leap year
sixth foot in my life dawg you five ten
just admit it
five turns six one no in between
god skipped that we went from five
eleven to six one but but you ate six
even yeah
god doesn't make mistakes but he never
made a man six foot even
that stamp wasn't made so like anybody
who says they're succeeding that ain't
true
that's why women always say you have to
be at least 6-1
let me tell you another tick tock
marketing thing that i think is pretty
clever that i saw um have you ever heard
of it's probably probably not it's
pretty pretty niche but this thing
called far cocktail
apartments i have it on here it's
f-a-r-k-a-t-k-t-e
so basically there's a woman on
on tick-tock and she's a real estate
broker or a leasing broker and i'll tell
you how i arrived at this so
somebody had tweeted out something which
was like hey if you needed a side hustle
that was going to generate like 3k to 5k
a month
um
and you could only kind of work like you
know let's say like
you know a couple hours and during the
week and and you know half a day on the
weekends or something like that what
would you do to do that if you didn't
know how to code
and one of the interesting answers was
oh i'd be a leasing agent because
if you can get an apartment leased up
you get i think the first month's rent
or something like that as the broker and
so the rent is going to be you know in
new york or san francisco or these big
cities rent's going to be like three
grand four grand five grand six grand
and so if you just lease one apartment
right so if you get one apartment at
least
you know that's 5k right there that's
pure profit essentially
and what i saw was that some people what
they're doing
is they're creating popular tick tock
accounts just showing unique spaces or
like in this case she shows like
hilariously i think hilariously bad
apartments like she'll walk into this
place she like all right this this
apartment this condo is
exquisite and like whatever you know
queens here and then she'll be like um
you know how many bedrooms is it there's
no bedrooms there's just this loft
actually it's not a loft actually it's
just this like area above the kitchen
where there's like a pipe above your
head but like there's like three inches
to go sleep up there if you can climb up
and like oh you know do you like the
soothing sounds of water well the toilet
keeps running so you'll have that zen
vibe and so she's like kind of making
fun of like how overpriced apartments in
new york are and for like how little you
get for how much you pay which is just a
great viral hook right so instead of
just
doing the literal thing which is go to
find an apartment be like hey guys
here's a great apartment she's finds
hilariously bad deals
makes that her tick tock or really good
deals and then she basically says
if you want an apartment come to me and
so um i don't know if this is exactly
her model but because i just looked at
it real quick but like i think that
would be a model that would work is
create content like we've seen this on
instagram there's an account called
zillow gone wild which is hilarious to
watch which is like it's just like crazy
ass homes from zillow and so you can
kind of make like house porn or like
apartment porn where it's like just
really interesting
stuff like really interesting apartments
or really interesting homes really
overpriced really underpriced whatever
and then use that as your lead gen for
like by the way do you actually just
want a two bedroom apartment like come
through like get it through me
like here's my listings uh like you can
actually see if you want like something
that's not like overpriced here's my
listings and like i think just doing
something like that you could have have
a lot of fun and build a pretty like
solid business i mean i'm sure she's
doing way more than 5k a month but i
just thought that was certainly an
interesting little model i looked up i
looked up
this word i've never heard that word
it's a i looked it up it's a yiddish
word that means poor quality
uh and so yeah but who's this lady
what's her handle
it's just that it's that word those were
she got far far [__] day apartments and
that's her tick tock she has 37 000
followers and like you know like here's
a huge loft in brunswick it'll have 108
000 views on that video right so she's
showing crazy these things but then she
has her actual she so she's like comedy
actor slash realtor if you want my real
rentals you know compass.com go go get
them all right like you can email little
crushes
yeah so i thought this was great and
it's like completely differentiated uh
from what most people do
and so like i'm trying this right now
with the milk road which is like i'm
really obsessed with this idea of like
you if you combine two things that are
usually not combined you don't have to
be great at either one of the things
because you've created a whole new
combination right like this happens in
food all the time or like
you've talked about this formula in food
like
jumbo donut it's like you don't need to
have the best donuts
just do a huge donut and then people
will come to you for for that right go
go for the biggest make a green
you know
purple ketchup green like you know it's
doritos tacos right like
uh it's not that it's better it's just
so different and so with milk road we're
doing this right now where i'm trying to
create like basically a
it's not funny enough or it'd just be
like a straight up like comedy thing
but it's like a lot of
yeah it's like this part yeah i don't
know why i'm trying to go for this like
far-fetched example
this podcast are we the richest no are
we the smartest no are we the best
prepared no do we have the best insights
and research absolutely not
are we the funniest no
but do we have the right combination of
like we were having a good time we make
ourselves laugh and make you laugh just
enough we're like it's business and it's
just enough business and just enough
make you laugh
and that's what like i'm trying that
with the milk road now i'm trying to do
the same thing it's like there's crypto
information there's a lot of people
trying to be the smartest guy in the
room with crypto it's like a big brains
contest you go into a room and
everybody's just trying to have this
like 9000 iq it's like well we want to
be smart but we're not going to be the
smartest because who the [__] knows
who's the smartest it's really hard but
like
we can also be
slightly funny and we would
differentiate ourselves from everybody
else doing crypto content and so i'm
pretty interested in this like this like
idea of stacking sk unique skills that
are like you don't have to be the best
at either you just have to be just
dangerous enough at both but if you
combine them you're completely
differentiated in your market
can i ask you about a crypto story
really quick that you you would might
know about and yeah i need you to
explain it to me so do you know anything
about sam bankman freed that's his name
right bankman of course
so how old is he is he under 30 still uh
he's like 29 30 31 i know i know he was
under 30 at once but is he still i
should know they are currently the
leading sponsor of the milk road so ftx
go get your go get your account so he is
30 years old exactly on the knot on the
dot all right
that was a bad joke i made by the way i
said i knew he was under 30 once but is
he still under 30. uh i was good
actually i didn't i just didn't pick it
up
um all right so this like basically when
he was 28 he was worth like 20 billion
dollars right
yeah he's the
i think he's probably i think him or the
guy from finance they're the richest
person from crypto besides whoever
satoshi is
that's crazy so and this
he said in an article the other day he's
like i'm thinking about spending a
hundred million dollars on the upcoming
presidential election but i'll probably
cap out at about a billion yeah and just
like that statement is just a ridiculous
statement to like not that it's wrong
it's just like a crazy
chain of words added together in one
sentence like i didn't think i would
hear someone say it let alone a 30 year
old
how
what type of person is this guy to
become that rich at like 28
he he also has a unique skill stack
which is that so he was like um i think
a trader or an analyst at jane street so
it's like kind of like smart quant type
guy
and then
uh you know i think i've told the story
before you know the story about the uh
the kimchi like arbitrage or whatever
you know this not exactly i know that
like he did some arbitrage but i don't
understand why bitcoin would be cheaper
in korea than it would in america
well it's all about like kind of like
access and the liquidity of the market
so like uh
some markets like for example japan is
where the access was the hardest so like
i think let's say this for example the
government's crack down on exchanges so
you can only get it in the black market
or on these small niche exchanges of
these foreign offshore exchanges there's
a lot of friction and so
because of that
and you can't access coinbase.com
yeah like at a given time in japan you
couldn't access you couldn't easily buy
bitcoin because of that to buy bitcoin
in japan you were paying a premium so in
theory you could let's say bitcoin is
priced at 30 grand you could buy bitcoin
for 30 grand in america and if you had a
way to sell it in japan you could sell
it for 32 000 and you could just
infinitely make a 2 000 spread and so
it's kind of like great how much capital
you got pour it all into bitcoin in the
us and then sell it all instantly in
japan and you're not really taking much
risk
because you're just quickly flipping it
for that premium and so a lot of people
were trying to do this i think there was
a spread of about five grand in japan or
something like that at the time but
nobody knew how like it wasn't easy to
go sell the thing in japan again if it
was that easy there wouldn't have been
the premium in the first place what he
found was that i think it was in korea
um
that he uh there was a smaller premium
but it was easier to get around
and so like what what they did was they
literally flew to korea or whatever and
they like talked to like local banks and
they were like hey we would like to have
an account
that will allow us to
uh you know wire money in significant
size every day in and out like can you
support that can you support that action
because i'm going to basically be
transferring in like you know call it
two million dollars in and two million
dollars out the same day
and it's just to be the same day
just calling down action makes it sound
cooler can you support that action
that's such a better word can you handle
that size that's my new shape that also
by the way just being like yeah we got
to be able to do it in size or like yeah
they're moving in size
[Laughter]
i'm just gonna say
action instead of the word amount so
like asking my wife how much like beef
she wants me to buy at the store
how much did you watch how much action
are you trying to get on these ribs
in terms of in terms of uh oat milk
are we trying to move sighs
yeah crazy
so basically what ended up happening was
he had this company like whatever
alameda research or whatever uh but like
he saw that the
um
i think it was like the kimchi premium
was like the big premium was like if
bitcoin was 10k in the us it was 15k in
korea and i think in japan there was a
smaller one and so he was he he was able
to do in japan and he made like
something like 20 million dollars doing
this arbitrage in like one summer
and it took him like flying there
finding a network of local banks that
would let him wire serious money in and
out and make sure that they could just
repeat these transactions on the same
day close so that they had the money
they were recycling a small amount of
money so i think it was like take two
million dollars they buy bitcoin they
sell it in japan they take the money
that they're made in japan they need to
be able to wire it back so that tomorrow
they can go buy again 2.2 million of
bitcoin based off of the extra that they
made and then they did the same thing
next day 2.4 million and they got it up
where they they eventually profited like
20 30 million so then he basically was
like all right
him and his like small team i guess um
like this little crew that was doing
this arbitrage did he have money ahead
of time or was he just like a like a
like living with roommates
living with roommates even now he lives
like he drives like an old beat up honda
or some [__] like that he sleeps like in
the office on a giant bean bag so
there's like tons of pictures of him
just like
passed out on a bean bag in front of his
desk and it's like it's actually like
two bean bags like upper body on one
feet on the other creates this tiny
little spf bridge between them and like
that's just the way this guy works and
he's like
you know he's vegan he
he's uh he's like he he practices things
called effective uh altruism i think is
what you call it and so
so that's his thing which is like his
goal is like this philosophy and the
goal is
make as much money as you can so that
you can give away as much money as you
can like that's the point of making
money is to give it away in the most
effective manner possible
and so it's like earn to give is the
like name of the um
um
is the name of the of the like
the the philosophy of what they do is
that so one of the things he's trying to
do is like
yeah that's what he says he's motivated
by so he's like you know he's donated
like i think he donated like he's
donated 200 million already of his like
net worth and he's um
and he's you know this thing about like
i i'm willing to donate up to a billion
dollars uh you know in the next one is
to like you know another way to make
change and it's not all political like
it's like where does the dollar have you
know the most effect and that sort of
thing
yeah he uh
did i also read an interview or is it
you told me where he was like
i don't even care about bitcoin like i'm
just doing this to make money like he
said something to the he's where he's
not like
yeah so there's a lot of people that are
like very missionary like if you listen
to brian armstrong from coinbase he's
like
uh he like lived in buenos aires and saw
like you know what happened to the
argentinian peso and he was like it's
not right like people around the world
are you know don't have access to like
economic freedom and uh you know they
live in a place where their currency
gets devalued like crazy and like
there's a better way and it's crypto i
believe that to my core and i'm gonna
like coinbase is gonna help more people
like get into crypto because i think
crypto is what matters in the world and
sam baker freed just sort of like
um
you know not that his mission is
different his mission is like i'm an
effective altruist i'm trying to give
away as much money as possible so i need
to make as much money as possible and in
order to do that i'm gonna just oh you
know whether you're selling this or that
like cool people wanted an effective
trading platform for crypto i'll build
that uh you know i know this product and
this need because i'm a trader so i'll
be able to like do it that way
that's baller man and there was a meme
of him the other piece of the
as you say the other piece of the effect
of altruism is like they really use like
they wanted to be evidence-based
that like um you know every dollar going
in is like having like you know sort of
like the greatest possible impact is
like one of their their big things like
how measurable is the impact
dude this guy's great there's a funny
meme of him going around basically this
guy his name's stan bankman free google
him and he looks like you'd want him to
look so he's kind of like a chubby
jewish guy who wears like new balance
shoes in like high socks and cargo
shorts and like an army green t-shirt
and like shaggy hair and a huge timex
watch
like that's like it looks like a [__]
look
yeah and he uh
there's a picture of him on stage
and it's like this beautiful interviewer
and then on his left is like giselle and
on the right is like some other model
like how do you clue i i forget like
these like you know smart like business
women who who are just like the most
gorgeous people you've ever seen and
he's sitting in the middle and they're
all like looking at him and it's like
get you get you a person who will look
at sam bakeman freed like giselle looks
at him or something like that and it's
hilarious yeah
yeah he's just kind of hunched over
oblivious to the whole thing it's great
is he is he like uh
what makes him special
um you know that's hard to say i haven't
met him we've met some of the other like
kind of people the ftx team like for
example their head of strategy is like
25 years old or something like that
he might be 24 and he's like the head of
strategy there he like started off in
customer service and is now the head of
strategy and so i think they just like
if i could just kind of comment on like
what you see as the culture for them is
like they go hard what i mean by that is
like they're like
they're really sharp they're like kind
of like quants and then they like work
like it just seems like they work very
hard and they they move as fast as
crypto moves which is very very fast and
they didn't like
there was no like invisible walls for
them like the companies based in the
bahamas they grew like crazy when they
wanted to do marketing they're like okay
go get steph curry and tom brady and
like you know larry david and that's
who's gonna be our spokesperson or
whatever like they pulled no expenses
they named they like bought arena like
he called somebody i know the guy who
we met the guy who
did the athlete rights for them
um and basically he was like yeah he got
on a call and i was like okay so like
what are your goals with like you know
sports sponsorships to help you know ftx
how are you going to measure this he
goes
um how much does it cost to have the
yankee stadium name renamed to ftx
stadium it's like
uh yeah i don't think that's even like
for sale he's like okay what about every
ad inside the stadium
and he's like uh that's a lot man like
maybe we should just like kind of like
crawl before we walk in before we run
and he's like i think it would be most
effective if we go get tom brady and
steph curry and yankees like um
you go do that and then tell me when you
have them you know like that was
essentially the call
and it was like you know name your price
and like that's what they did and guess
what they got all of them and it's like
a pretty impressive strategy where it's
like there's not like any like you know
tiptoeing around in anything i love
the those people i call them freaks and
i love them i love these freaks i love
freaks
he also is one of my favorite twitter
followers like i don't know if you do
follow him on twitter he posts awesome
threads that are like not like again
it's not propaganda for his company but
it actually is effectively propaganda
for the company so he'll just be like
you know
here's my thoughts on like raising money
here's what actually happens
and he'll be like yeah investors they
want us to do this and at first i
thought that's just self-serving
[__] but then i realized actually
the game theory is this and then he like
just talks he'll just lay out these long
threads and like he's like look i'm not
saying this is ftx's point of view this
is like
my late night thoughts about this topic
and when you see him think out loud
you're like oh wow this guy's just
incredibly sharp and he sees both sides
of it he's kind of like an independent
thinker and so he's one of the best
follows on on twitter
do you think working with him do you
think that he's he's obviously has some
intensity but is he like a hustle hustle
like let's work like why
like alf this alpha type of guy
i don't get that vibe i don't get wolf
of wall street i don't get the he's not
genghis khan took over 30 of the thing
it's like
it's more like obsession meets like you
know we i don't know if this got cut i
think it's got cut out of our previous
podcast where we were like we kind of
admire the like aspergersy personality
because it has like uh the ability to
like focus really intensely and the
ability to like think not like
think for yourself and not think just
like oh what is the norm what societal
norms like let me just go with that so
to me it's like when he says that let's
go get the yankees and tom brady it's
not because like let's go swing our big
d around here and let's go show who's
boss it's like well it seems like the
most effective thing to do if we're
trying to build trust would be go to the
most trusted athletes and like get them
and on a cost you know a cost per you
know fan basis they're actually the most
effective even though the total gross
dollar amount is higher right like to me
that's how his brain works not like you
know be sweet dude if we go get like
let's go get the [__] yankees bro
like it's not that and so um
he's like uh like who what's that the
largest reach okay that makes sense yeah
just whatever's number one in that chart
just do that right exactly like well if
this has the arbitrage then like let's
put all of our money into it and like
let's hedge it over here like that it's
more like that and so
and so i think that when they
just in the same way like the intensity
of the company is high but i don't think
it's because it's like
bro we got to grind if we want to make
it you know like you know uh oh you take
weekends off you know you're soft you
know like it's not that it's more like
oh i haven't eaten in 36 hours because
i've just been like really interested in
this problem and i'm staring at my
screen and i forgot to eat and i forgot
to shower and i also i guess i'll just
sleep on this bean bag because that way
i don't need to commute because
commuting wastes at least you know an
hour a day and like why would i waste an
hour of my day like you know i'm just i
sleep on this beanbag in fact it's
ergonomic or whatever you know like i
think that's more how the brain works
where it's like this hyper rationalism
is what i would call it
do um i wonder what he's like as a ceo
like do you think he holds one-on-one
meetings and like
because he just does not look like we
should have him on
him and the head of whatever they wanted
to come on the pod so uh
i think they're protecting him a little
bit like he's now super busy with like
press applications or whatever like so
there i think they were trying to have
like their the number two guy in the
company come on the pod and so this this
guy brett uh so i think he'd be really
interesting too uh but you know
everybody wants sbf because he looks
like he he's the zuckerberg right like
cheryl might be the the secret weapon
and the one who actually runs the show
but like
zuck is this like alien character that
people are fascinated with and they want
to like poke them and be like oh look
it moves you know and so well i would
love to get sam on
i wouldn't mind having a guy who
is his boss you know a guy who works for
him as long as the guy coming on would
be
cool we're only gonna ask you about sam
is that cool yeah like oh wait no i
don't think you understand the
assignment we don't care about like you
that's not annoying right
yeah
dude it's like if i meet someone who's
like oh man love the podcast i'm like
dude great so that's so glad to meet a
fan and he's like
sam's so awesome what's it like to be
around samuel oh [__] you dude i'm busy
like i'm not gonna sit here talking
about sam
we had a couple of guests and they're
like cool and they like say like oh yeah
i worked with steve jobs um and like
wait wait all right let's just
let's just only focus scrap your current
thing
so as long as they're okay like if they
understand the assignment that it's
strictly a like we're just here to like
learn like joe rogan had this guy who
worked at spacex and they talked about
what it's like to work to elon for elon
and i was like oh just let's just only
focus on that thing the whole go to
space stuff is cool but just tell me
what it's like to work with elon and
that's what we as long as they
understand that's the assignment i'm on
board
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
here's another kind of like interesting
like intensity teamwork thing that i
think is you know close enough
transition have you seen this business
called a team
like uh i think it's because i think
it's just a letter a and then dot team
is there well you know that's like a mad
a famous tv show right you remember uh
mr t mr t or whatever
yeah yeah all i know is that much i
don't i've never seen anything so so
it's that same oh like i think they're
kind of playing all that branding a
little bit in the sense that like
uh the idea is basically so they just
raised 60 million dollars and they
raised it from nfx who i i really res uh
nfx was early in them and said good
things i i respect that effect so made
me pay attention now this is an idea
that's been around it's been tried
but maybe the time is right now and so
that's why this is interesting to me so
let me kind of give you my backstory of
this idea and i want to hear what you
think if you think this is a good idea
or a bad idea so i once heard neval on a
podcast talk about like the future of
work
he he was basically like naval was like
you know i
um
i don't buy this whole i don't believe
that we're going to live in a world
where you work nine to five sitting at a
desk in some office for one company you
work there for 30 years and already you
see that shifting like instead of
working at a place for 30 years then
getting your pen in when you retire and
they like you know have a cake cutting
ceremony in the in the lobby for you as
they send you off to your death like
okay now people started to hop jobs more
and then people started to work you know
remote and freelance and neval's thing
was like he's like i think the future of
work is like ocean's 11. he goes you're
gonna have your crew the same way that
ocean's 11 is this badass team of like
you know you got the pickpocket guy you
got the ninja you have the like the
comms guy you have the planner you have
the like um you know the guy who can go
gather intel you have the hot girl who's
the distraction and you have this you
know you got brad pitt george clooney
all right so that's the team and it's
like you're just gonna get a message
which says all right guys round up like
we got one we got a mission to go on and
everybody meets up and everybody
everyone's doing other stuff and it's
like what's the mission oh like you know
ocean's elevens we're gonna rob this
bank or whatever and then for um
for work it's gonna be like all right
here's this brand that's trying to
whatever they're killing the us they're
trying to expand into india and so you
might be the ocean's 11 team that
continuously gets called on to take a
brand and expand them into india and
like you you wake up you get a page uh
you know your pager basically goes off
and says
we need you the bat signal is up you all
congregate you've all worked together so
you know you come as a group who's good
at accomplishing certain types of
missions you do those missions you rate
each other you rate the company that
hired you they rate you you rate each
other on your team you go on your way
and you get called in for the next
mission and the money hits your bank and
so naval kind of describes this thing
and he's like you won't just have one
team like you'll probably float around
with a couple teams like if you're the
pickpocket you've got like three teams
that can call on you and um and it just
works that way so you get reputation
that's built not on a resume but through
this like verified ratings of like i've
actually worked with this person
you have um
not continuous work you get called on
when there's a mission you sprint you
crush it then you relax until the next
mission you can work as much or as
little as you want you may or may not
even know the identities of the other
people you could be like my name is my
nickname is just whatever star wing and
i just go in and people don't know me a
star wing and i just that's how i work
and like that's the future of work so
that kind of fascinated me when he he
described it and he did it in the naval
way which was like you know one tenth of
the words i just used but twice is
interesting
and now i'm starting to see some
startups pop up that are doing this and
to me a team is an idea of that where
they're like oh you want to build um an
e-commerce website well we have the
designer the front-end developer the
back-end developer and the like
conversion optim optimizer and like
they'll just
swoop in and they'll just do it for you
in like two weeks you'll get a better
product than whatever and here's the big
lump sum payment you do for that team
this is so amazing i saw a meme the
other day where was the guy he goes i so
look forward to the day where i'm just
sitting at a bar and a stranger walks up
and says i'm putting together a team and
i look at them and respond i'm in when
we leave
and it was just like that
yeah i live in the duffel bag you know
yeah
i'm putting together i'm putting the
team together you win uh dude this is
awesome their site is
amazing this is one of the best landing
pages i've seen in a long time it's a
dot team
look at those landing pages it's pretty
good the hero image is really good and
then um yeah the exactly just succinctly
describe what they're doing so you just
get on you just log on and you see it
it's a relatively strange concept and
they describe it in like two sentences
wonderfully this is awesome i'm not
sure i don't i think it's quite bold to
say it's the future of work i don't
think that that's what it is but i think
it's like a subset of freelancing that's
going to be amazing
yeah exactly not everybody but in the
same way like the gig economy made it so
that
you know i can like a thing that didn't
happen 10 years ago or whatever like was
you wake up
you like hop in your car you open up
your phone
this guy wants a ride over here drive
over there pick him up drop him off cash
hit your bank you know he you made 16
for that ride oh you want to go you want
to stop working because you want to go
pick up your daughter from school you
swipe to log off you're off work now you
want to get back on later you know at
midnight and take people to the airport
all right you can do that again like
that whole gig economy thing where your
phone just gives you jobs like gives you
work that will just pay you small micro
like payments off your micro tasks
that's pretty cool
and that's like a thing that uber and
like taskrabbit and doordash
all brought to the table so
i feel like there might be the next
version of that which is like for highly
skilled cross discipline like i know i
could do this for example like i have
three or four people where it's like
that's the great developer this is the
great designer i'll be the marketing guy
and this guy will be the you know
whatever the
problem is is that they're not available
like to do stuff and this is creating an
opportunity for them to be available but
if like i've gone on i've gone to the
shopify marketplace and i've used upwork
and oftentimes when i use upwork it's
just like a guy in india who's like the
face and he's got like a team of like
eight guys and like isn't that kind of
what's already happening they just
packaged this in a far more
sophisticated and sexy way yeah they did
in a more sexy way and i think it's more
for premium like things so like in the
same way that like if you don't want the
india thing but you want like it's sort
of like what an agency does but what
typically what agencies do they specify
they they specialize in one vertical so
it's like we do seo
we do facebook ads we do copywriting and
what this is saying is like no you're
trying to launch a marketplace you're
trying to launch a new nft marketplace
well you're gonna need somebody who's
great at email marketing you're gonna
need an engineer who knows smart
contracts you're gonna need a designer
you're gonna need a social media person
so like whatever they give you the six
cross-disciplinary people that are good
at building marketplaces and that's just
like a different cut of the same idea of
agencies
this is awesome this is one of the
cooler companies i think i've seen
lately this is amazing yeah how'd you
find this
uh because the guys i followed at nfx
they were like hey this company's grown
really fast like fast there i forgot
what they said but it was like growing
super fast and i was like how fast and
uh you know that's why i started looking
to it and it reminded me of that like
that dreamy idea that neval had brought
up and i was like oh maybe
now with kovid maybe now the time has
changed where like there's enough really
talented people that are no longer like
locked into jobs um because they're
not they've got like all the right
people if you go to like their team it
says that their their featured advisors
are the guy who started fiverr which is
crazy the guy who started fiber also
started lemonade that's pretty wild the
ceo of upwork
so like they've got all the right people
on board
wow yeah this is an amazing company this
is a badass find i've never i've never
heard of these guys
yeah that's cool um all right take
another idea off this list and uh
another topic of this list let's do that
um
uh let's do that
yeah i literally never read docusign i
just sign
uh this is more like i just needed to
verify with you do you also do this like
dude when i get a docusign
i'm not reading it i'm not gonna lie you
can scan me pretty easily
have you seen the south park episode
where like it's like what they do is um
they create you know what a caterpillar
is
no so it's like do i want to know
they take a chain of six people and
and they like i think i know
they sell their mouths to the person's
butt and you just gotta stay there okay
and apple apple does that to people
because it says it in the terms and
conditions in itunes when you sign up
and the whole episode is like whoa stan
you didn't read the terms and conditions
of apple before you click yes that's
crazy of course like you have to go do a
caterpillar now because that's what it
said i can't believe you didn't read it
and it's like this whole thing but um
dude i've been getting docusigns lately
where they literally just send me the
sign page and they don't even send me
yeah yes people are like hey here's the
document it's just a one underline and
it says sign here i'm like signed what
what am i saying yeah it's called the
signature package and basically i've got
in the context of a company that i've
invested in they need me to sign
paperwork for some reason because
they're raising a new add a new
valuation at a higher valuation and they
literally just send me the signature
packet and like i have
it's four or six things and i'm just it
just says like sam parr and then a lion
and the signing and i have no idea what
i'm signing and so yeah like a yes i do
that because i just don't read the stuff
and b sometimes they don't even send me
the stuff to read they just send me they
just sign i have no idea what it means
do you get that yeah i've been getting
those and i'm like i'm like all right
it's one thing if i'm not gonna read it
for you to not even write it it's like a
whole level another level of arrogance
here and like you know
poor form that we're taking
what do those guys do
he was based in new york
yeah
why see more butts asking me to sign
this stuff they're just messing with me
that's crazy it's like you know when
people when people really want to get us
to respond they'll like venmo us money
or they're like pay palace money being
like i'm being super creative to like to
reach you to get you to read my message
or whatever and i'm like
it doesn't really doesn't really work i
don't really like that and it makes me
feel uncomfortable and like you know um
generally the people i want to meet
never do that so i'm like uh you know
generally this is not a good signal for
you
the other day this these guys were
emailing me to try their stuff and
they're like what are you soft you're
not up for the challenge and i just i
was just like i am not up i am not up
for the challenge
and they just replied with okay
[Laughter]
i am not up for the challenge
i think people they hear us out here and
we're joking around and they're like uh
what if i take that joke to the next
level
and i make it weird and they don't know
me
they somehow think that's going to work
it's like this works as me and sam have
known each other for like 10 years
and the jokes are meant to be jokes
they're not serious it's like then you
take the you take that same idea you
make it serious and you do it from a
stranger it's like no no it's not the
same thing
yeah
i i actually don't like the annoying um
the other day this guy
sent me an email and in the subject line
it said like
you know like you're a c word sucker
and uh he's like made you open
and i was like oh i don't i don't like
that that i find that to be
inappropriate and not cool like i'm not
on board with that and
that's what he said
but i can totally see how somebody would
listen to this podcast and think uh
they'll love that
yeah or like like
why are you approaching me
it's like we're we're that's what we're
doing we're like i love this copywriting
and you know just do what you got to do
and for the hustle i was super annoying
getting people to be conference speakers
like yeah but i don't like when it
happens to me
yeah i didn't even call someone like a
little [__] like people will call me
that they're like what's up you little
[__]
like dude i don't know you who's doing
that
somebody was doing that somebody who
worked for us was doing that right
yeah yeah yeah i have not called them
out but they called us a little [__]
and i'm like dude you're an intern don't
talk to me like that and like my friends
don't even call me a little [__]
what are you talking about
it was like i think it was an intern
that called us that
oh i know i think it was a breyo
a bray you used to call us a little bit
i wasn't gonna call them out
you're like i'm not going to call them
out oh unless it's you in which case
it was
you he was our uh producer and he'd be
like uh
time to work you little [__] or
something
dude don't talk to me like that i'm
gonna talk to you like that
it's like why are you calling me that
yeah
yeah bray you came in really hot
uh you gave it really
yeah i know i mean i love them and he
could talk to me that now that we're
friends and not co-workers but when we
were co-workers i was like
dude
i was like offended i was like please
don't call me that that i don't like
that uh zilinski deep fake what's that
that's a longer one i went down this
rabbit hole of like
the history of the internet like how it
came out
pretty quick just crazy stuff uh i'm not
gonna do that one right now that one's
too long but um
okay so zelinski deep fake so
people know about deep fakes which is
like i think i think a lot of people who
listen us probably know about deep fakes
but if you don't it's basically
the way that you can photoshop a picture
to kind of like edit and make it look a
certain way and it looks real but like
oh no that's been photoshopped
you can now do that with video which
kind of means
right
now
it's not yet there are some but like you
know in a small way like the uh snapchat
face filter is essentially like a a bit
of a deep fake there's this have you
seen the baby one or the one where it
makes you sad and cry
no
is that on snapchat yeah or it's on
instagram i think they like show
someone's face and they're like hey sean
why you so sad why are you crying and
you're like what i'm not crying at all
but like it looks like you're crying and
sad
it's like that's one version of it then
there's like uh this there's this app i
forgot to call it some moves or
something like that it's like some dance
app but like you basically take a
picture of yourself standing there and
then it'll make it look like your body
it'll make you look like a great dancer
like you could go post something on
twitter i think you might have done this
or it's like
i think that's how you found it i did it
it looked like i was breakdancing
yeah you're like breakthrough it's like
you're just jamming out on a wednesday
it's like whoa sam can break dance but
it's like that looks not quite right
wait a minute and it's like oh yeah
that's like a deep fake basically it's a
fake video
and so this is but they're getting
better and better like you'll see them
do this with like oh my god did you hear
obama saying the n-word it's like what
no and then you watch this video it's
like it's a deep fake but they could
like mimic his voice and his lips moving
uh and talking doing something and then
this is happening it's like it's
becoming a big problem in the porn
industry because people are doing this
like oh there's some girl in my college
and i'll just take her picture and i'll
make it look like she shot this you know
sex tape or whatever and people are like
dude that's like you know really effed
up but like the technology can do that
uh it can do that now it can basically
makes make it look like somebody was
doing something that they never did
and so this is becoming a problem and
there's one with zilinski the ukrainian
whatever president prime minister
whatever it is and like there's this
video uh going around of him talking and
it's a real there's a real video and
then there's the deep fake video where
it shows like a a trail powder of uh
cocaine on his desk
and the russian propagandists are saying
uh like look at this your president's
breaking down he's using drugs that's
why he's saying all this crazy stuff
and they made it they added some stuff
in the background of the video and i'm
like oh man this is just gonna get super
crazy of like
how do you know what you can trust if
you can't trust your eyes and ears
anymore like
how are we gonna like prosecute crimes
how are we gonna like prevent people
from like just completely slandering
your reputation right are we gonna
prevent people from
like um you know like the this was what
people said that the russians were doing
with hillary like during the election
was like
they were showing propaganda like
hillary said this about black people
they were promoting that in like
predominantly black counties where they
were trying to sway the vote and get
them to not turn out for hillary it's
like it was fake right but it was like
misinformation and so to me i'm like
this deep fake thing is going to be like
a real real problem and i think there's
opportunity
well there's one answer uh that a buddy
was trying to work on which was
basically a way to like certify the auth
like the original mint of the video so
it's like you can basically encrypt the
original video so that if anybody wants
to see like oh this video of this guy
saying this crazy thing is this was this
the what was originally shot from the
phone
and so he was trying to do that but
really what you need is you need the
phone makers to participate because it
has to be done at like the hardware
level because any anything else it could
be tampered with it's like well if it's
just a video file i encrypt and i could
just like encrypt it later i could edit
it first then encrypt it so it has to be
done like as it's being shot the i you
know apple and google and samsung or
whoever these people are they're gonna
have to bake it in where like every
video comes with a seal of authenticity
and then that's gonna be a cat and mouse
game of like can that be faked uh
because you could put somebody in prison
for like a fake murder you know like
that's how crazy this is gonna get if we
don't have a way to fight against deep
fakes
by the way um go to the chat of
riverside and click the link i just sent
you
tell me what you think about that deep
fake
oh that's you you dancing dude that's
great
yeah he said announcement while you guys
have been taking this time to chill your
boy's been learning to dance get on my
level and it's a video of you okay so
it's get get get sway so sway is the
name of the app so get swayed dot app is
the name of the thing
this is hilarious
although it made you a little look a
little chunky here you look you look a
little bit like will ferrell in this
video so you know well yeah you could
dance but it also looks like you put on
like the cove with 30.
i i was that that was pre-influencer um
well it's like glitching it's like it's
like it's like it's not it's not your
actual thing it's like because you're
moving so fast it's like it has to make
it fuzzy it can't have like a really
sharp like line it's pretty good
obviously
it's pretty good
click left go to the left one there's
another one i mean
it's pretty amazing for just like a free
app
what do you mean click left there's no
left there's a video to your left
on the next picture to the left
uh on your profile okay
i mean like they're it's it's a pretty
amazing what's the app called get sway
yeah
yeah i think it's pretty amazing
yeah anyway i hope some smart people out
there are working on defects i'm curious
what people are going to do the only
solution i know is doing it at the
hardware the operating system level and
even that's probably not perfect but if
somebody does figure out a perfect way
to do this that's going to be very very
valuable technology
and i saw the obama thing yeah they made
them can i say some crazy [__] uh
yeah man i i agree it is kind of scary
um
well ben what do you think how do we do
we gotta get it
very very eclectic very eclectic but
like all very interesting stuff and uh
and the cola stuff was uh was all time
can't wait to drink a cola with you guys
what was your favorite one
your favorite non cola doing the cola
one which ones you like
i i think eating caramel is my favorite
it's just simple
and amazing so unexpected
i think my favorite was actually we were
just eating spaghetti kissing in the
middle well all of a sudden
me and my co-founder were doing the uh
kissing the spaghetti thing where you
each take one end put in your mouth get
me in the middle and what we realized
was that the recession
yeah
and then we realized
yeah that's a good one the best part is
like but the thing about co-founders is
so you don't address the first part
and you gotta do this like in a keynote
that's like a product like a steve job
product advertisement i'd never address
it and never look at the office grabbing
each other's butts and then it hit us
why stop there you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we're out of here
this is great
[Music]
you